[Música]
bienvenida a mi compañera daniela
blandón daniela cerró hoy el peor
semestre para los mercados desde que
inició la pandemia así es andrés muy
buenas noches pues recordemos la
inflación ha estado detrás de la calidad
del mercado en general este año ya que
las empresas aumentan los precios de
todo desde alimentos hasta ropa y los
consumidores se ven más presionados eso
ha hecho que la reserva federal y otros
bancos centrales hayan estado elevando
agresivamente las tasas de interés esto
para tratar de frenar el crecimiento
económico y de esta manera enfriar la
inflación y las tasas de interés son el
peor de nemi el peor enemigo de las
acciones porque los inversionistas
comienzan a recibir más rendimientos de
otros activos menos riesgosos y eso
desencadena en una nueva preocupación
escuchamos cuáles
ciertamente podríamos estar en una
reflexión en este momento si se observa
lo que sucedió en el primer trimestre lo
que empujó el pib a territorio negativo
fue una reducción en el gasto público
pero aquí en el segundo trimestre como
resultado de la inflación que se mantuvo
alta ha habido una destrucción de la
demanda
en las tasas de interés más altas están
afectando a la vivienda están afectando
el gasto de los consumidores entonces
eso podría ser suficiente para ver otra
impresión negativa del pib en el segundo
semestre lo que provocaría dos
trimestres consecutivos de crecimientos
negativos
daniela el número como estuvieron los
principales indicadores bueno comencemos
por eeuu las acciones tecnológicas los
minoristas y otras empresas que dependen
directamente del gasto de los
consumidores han registrado algunas de
las mayores pérdidas el índice nasdaq
que es el que aglutina a las
tecnológicas fue el más golpeado del
cemento del semestre y ha perdido una
tercera parte de su valor ahora vamos
con el índice standard and poor's que es
probablemente el que los analistas
siguen más de cerca porque es el que
agrupa las 500 empresas más valiosas en
bolsa este perdió un 20,6 por ciento
desde su récord de comienzos de año en
la peor pérdida semestral desde 1970 en
europa entonces en medio de una
inflación récord en la zona euro los más
afectados fueron los bancos bolsas como
la de alemania perdieron un 20 por
ciento londres cayó un 4,5 por ciento en
los seis meses terminados en junio en
américa latina' los índices cerraron
también su peor semestre desde marzo de
2022 en el semestre por ejemplo la bolsa
de sao paulo bajó un 6% y solo la bolsa
de argentina subió y él si nos vamos a
los commodities del precio del petróleo
se trepó 40 por ciento hasta los 106
dólares en el caso del w y de referencia
para el golfo de mexico el frente de
referencia para europa aumentó más del
45 por ciento y por eso es que los
precios de los combustibles están tan
altos a nivel mundial cerramos con el
bitcoin el precio de la prescripto
moneda más grande y conocida del mundo
ha perdido alrededor del 60 por ciento
este año inició por encima de los 47 mil
dólares y ya está un poco menos de 19
mil cambiando de tema colombia subió sus
tasas de interés claro y siguiendo
también con esta misma línea
hablando de alta inflación de banco
centrales subiendo tasas pues el banco
de la república de colombia decidió
subir los tipos de interés como nunca
antes lo había hecho al menos en 24 años
que llevan haciéndole seguimiento lo
hizo en un punto porcentual y medio las
tasas de referencia
ahora son del 7,5 por ciento cuando en
diciembre del año pasado se ubicaban
apenas un 25 por ciento y la razón es la
misma que los bancos centrales están
tratando de hacerle frente al aumento de
precios encareciendo el crédito después
de tener los niveles históricamente
bajos en la pandemia adicionalmente
también hay otra noticia económica en
colombia y es que el presidente electo
gustavo petro quien tomará posesión el
próximo 7 de agosto designó ya a su
ministro de hacienda se trata de josé
antonio ocampo un reconocido economista
de corte progresista y favorable al
mercado que tendrá ahora sobre sus
hombros mantener a flote la cuarta
economía de américa latina daniela cifra
del día 15 mil empleos
y perdidos de las empresas tecnológicas
dejan en eeuu estas crisis según the
washington post que dice que en mayo se
perdió ese número de empleos como parte
de la estrategia de las compañías de
hacerle frente a una posible recesión
solamente la plataforma de streaming en
netflix ha despedido a 450 empleados en
poco más de un mes y otros como uber
meta y microsoft están reduciendo la
contratación también hablando con la
información económica muchas gracias
seguimos con más